good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy Monday
squirrel friends how's everyone doing
I'm sitting down with my former best
friend current Thief Jackie O hey Jackie
O let's talk about your sweatshirt let's
talk about my sweatshirt that Claudia
got for Florida that she leaves in my
guest room closet and a few weeks ago I
raided her closet the [__] doesn't come
and she's got some cute [__] and then I
had to snatch it
so I just want to say I'm really
actually flattered that I purchased
something that you'd like because you're
very like fashion girly and I'm like a
slob Kebab so no you're so fashioned
everyone see that Fendi dress Friday
night with the matching Fendi bag Okay
so
I'm not like so mad but I do expect that
to be returned when I do travel of
course because I spent a lot of time
curating my you know Floridian wardrobe
and for you to just like kind of come in
and disrupt that is very disruptive what
are you gonna do about it this is
literally giving me PTSD to like when we
were kids and the only thing we would
fight about was stealing other people's
clothes and I had nothing like steel
worthy because again like I've never had
you know an eye for passion so I was
always getting in trouble not you know
um yelling at other people but I feel
like now we're so generous with one
another like I'm so generous with you
you Mitch are so like you will let
someone borrow something that is like
your nicest piece that you haven't worn
yet you will let someone wear it before
you it's so nice thank you yeah no it
brings me joy to like help you girlies
get dressed and make you look nice you
look nice thanks
like when you and snitch were here um
for a few days when I had already went
on vacation and you guys were in my
closet and then like snitch looked so
great for New Year's Eve everyone was
like the CMA dress the CME dress like it
got another life it's it sure as hell
won't be fitting me anytime soon that's
just like actual maturity because the
Fendi dress that you um mentioned I have
had this Fendi dress in my house for
five years I bought it on the real real
it was actually 25 I couldn't could not
believe it and when it arrived it was
supposed to be a dress it barely fit as
a sweater
um and I never wore it and then when you
were in my closet you were like oh my
God like this is perfect for me can I
have it and I was like no even though I
literally never worn it it was probably
never going to fit and I should have
just given it to you but on Friday I
needed something to wear and I tried it
on I was like We'll see and it fit it
was still a little tight but it fit and
I'm actually glad that I didn't give it
to you
but now would you let me borrow it or no
now that I've already worn it it is all
yours got it okay that's that's sweet
so it's kind of like a big day here
because last week we were speaking a lot
about our green initiative
um the toast is going green and today we
have a new update in our going green you
know Jackie's always clicking away at
her iPad and I've decided to get one too
because
you know when I do my ads and I have
those curds it's a waste of paper and I
think Greta I think mostly just a waste
of time for you to be taping your curds
all day no and I have to buy so many ink
cartridges for the printer it's a lot
it's actually wasteful like between the
paper the electricity the cartridges and
you know those cartridges are like not
[__] recyclable I got an iPad and I'm
pretty sure an iPad isn't recyclable but
at least I could use this for like 10
years
yeah yeah and I heard you got a call
from Greta
I I did get a call from and what did she
say she said she said how dare you
she said how dare you and I said Greta
you're 100 right I've been using too
much paper gee that's what I call her
and that's why I bought this iPad this
morning right before the toast I'm gonna
get like a cool case like you you know
some more branding but that's the latest
update in our green initiative now when
I think about it a little further and
like keep
theorizing I think paper is so much more
recyclable than this I know but why are
people always saying it's a way like
like it's waste of paper because you
have to chop down trees to cut paper and
trees create oxygen they do I love trees
but you can recycle paper and make
amazing things I mean you could if I had
taken all the paper I've used for all
the ads over the last five years I could
have made like a sick paper mache mobile
for Harry's crib
he actually he knew that but he said
he's all good thank you Auntie he didn't
want it no no he's he said it was so
sweet of you but that's just like not he
said quote not my personal brand
wow okay um whatever
um so let's catch up a little bit I
actually didn't speak to you a lot this
weekend I I hit the town on Friday night
and then I just kind of like laid low
for the rest of the weekend just
recovering but I got to hang out with
Shannon which was just such a delight
like
so jealous it looked so fun it was we
went to dinner at The Nines which is the
restaurant that we went to for your
birthday celebration in November and
I've been there yeah I've been and
they've kind of like changed up their
Vibe because at like 11 45 like the
there's a it's like a piano bar which is
like really upscale and swanky and
they're playing like Billy Joel and then
a DJ comes in like everybody was getting
up on the tables and like dancing it was
so fun I had no idea what was going on I
was like why is everyone standing it got
so fun and then we went out to a new
club called Lucy's that everyone has
been to and I haven't been to yet it was
so fun and I was just like with the
young kids I mean at two o'clock I was
deceased I was drinking Red Bull I
actually like I'm getting old like I I
was like taking like I was drinking and
I had a few shots but like I stopped
drinking at like 12 30 because like I
just couldn't anymore and I was like
chugging Red Bull and I was leaving a
two in Shannon and Margo were like
you're leaving I'm like it's two
yeah that's how it starts
no I'm definitely I'm definitely like I
can't keep up with the kids no that you
have a few like you have a few more
years in you but I will say like phase
one of phasing out and it's like a 20
face process so don't worry is to stop
drinking after midnight no nothing good
is coming up those drinks no and I'm
still having a good time so yeah alerts
those drinks are they're only gonna feel
it tomorrow like they're not gonna
enhance the evening and I hope like
anyone who I saw on Saturday night like
doesn't hear this but it was just like
the night of seeing people like from a
past life
whom I genuinely could not place if my
life [__] depended on it and I was so
grateful to Shannon because like I was
with Shannon so anytime someone would be
like this is my friend Shannon yes so I
was like oh by the way this is my friend
Shannon and Shannon would be like hi and
they were like hey I'm Ashley or
whatever I was like oh Ashley yeah it
was it was happening like back to back
non-stop it was also really dark I was
like really drunk and you know me like
the worst memory of all time and it was
people from like actual former lives
maybe you need glasses
unique glasses that are like Google
Glass that function it's like Anne
Hathaway and Devil Wears Prada where
they like scan the face and they just
like bring up their Facebook profile
which by the way they could probably do
in two [__] seconds yeah no like I
feel like police like they'll they'll
literally have a camera on someone and
then like end with face identification
like it'll show you like their mug shot
or whatever facial recognition yeah okay
that's what I need because it was
mortifying
um yeah and that's the future then I
really spent the weekend catching up on
stuff I am all caught up in the new
season of drag race and I had something
to tell you so for the first time you
know dragon's like this really old
school art it's like it kind of reminds
me of comedy in the sense like it
happens on social media but like it's
very old school and like traditional
like the clubs is how you get
um got it like how you get an audience
so for the first time ever they had like
influencers on and I know these
influencers they're a Duo from La
they're twins sugar and spice and you
their aesthetic is so you it's like dull
Kawaii they're like brats that's like
their whole vibe but they're not really
um like well versed in
performing drag they just like do it on
Tick Tock they have 10 million followers
and so they came they competed
separately but like they were you know
twins and everyone was like so mean to
them because like it's the fellow Queens
the fellow Queens I just kind of like
you know not taking them seriously and
like making fun of them for being like
influencers and like not having a ton of
they started you know a little bit
before the pandemic so they didn't have
a lot of time to like go to clubs and do
shows and performances and I have to say
like they they did pretty good one of
them spoiler alert
one of them has gone home already but
not before some like really experienced
queens and like the queen who was so
mean to them on the first week she went
home first and I just loved to see it
Irene Dubois she was such a bully it was
just it was kind of like a jealousy
thing too you know yeah yeah it's
jealousy but it is also like a little
bit of bitterness where it's like we've
been working so hard to do all of these
things that like you don't have to do I
mean it does sound exactly like comedy
yeah where people have like a digital
platform and that parlays into something
and the comedians who have been like
toiling all of these years hustling in
small clubs yeah but I do think as we
always say the cream always Rises you
have to trust the process yeah and if in
that process that influencer who had a
leg up or whatever does make it all the
way then they're really that good a
hundred percent so they've made a lot of
changes to drag race this season and I'm
so here for it the episodes used to be
like 90 minutes I would have to skip
through like a lot of the stuff like the
judge's deliberation and I think MTV or
someone made them cut their episodes
down now they're like an hour 40 minutes
if you just watch it on like apple or
whatever it's so much better people are
mad I'm not you know me I cannot watch
something that long like I'm so here for
the new phone you need to get on quibby
be watching like 60 second shows
literally literally
um and so the best part of the Season
every game is so is this Sarah official
recap
like I'm not gonna be I'm like I like to
batch episodes I'm not going to be doing
it all the time but like yeah this is my
recap are you gonna are you gonna recap
it again at the end of this show and
like a recap this is it this is it I'm
just trying to figure out where to slot
in my Dope Sick recap oh um
you could go right after me okay okay
okay I was gonna wait till the end of
the show but it's too important and
we're already here so let's just here we
are yeah um so the best part of the
Season every season is The Challenge
called snatch game it's kind of how like
everyone at you know project Project
Runway used to look forward to like the
unconventional materials challenge this
is like the challenge that everyone's
obsessed with it's a game show that they
play
um but everyone has to be doing an
impersonation of someone
so like semi-con the person who won I
think last year got Mick did Paris like
you have to be really it's like it's
very hard it's all improv and you have
to be in character the whole time and
everyone does like a lot of the same
celebrities it's like kind of boring
um but every now and then somebody does
something like last season
um or no two seasons ago someone did
Harriet Tubman and it was pure comedy
like it was very funny so you have to
get creative because this Show's been on
for 15 Seasons everyone's done you know
the classic the usuals somebody did I
think her name is Lucy I'm I'm still
it's only like four episodes in I cannot
keep track of everyone's names it's like
the bachelor I mean you should have seen
her a Friday night trying to see people
that she knows right Jackie they Lucy
did the most incredible Joan Rivers I
swear to God it was Joan Rivers
reincarnated
she was a star I believe she won oh my
God it was sick and every now and then
somebody tries to do like somebody new
you have to do like a really established
celebrity but like somebody did Trisha
Paytas and someone but he did bretman
Rock and the point of the game is like
you sit in your little game show Cube
and you like improv back and forth with
Rue and like Rue doesn't know what who
Trisha Paytas is you know it totally
fell flat it was so embed it was like
really actually awkward snatch game can
either be the funniest thing you'll ever
see or so painful like you have to die
that's also funny but it reminds me of
your jamaic costume yes like completely
falling flat like nobody knows who you
are like none of the references it was
so bad but some of them were so good
like somebody did the Mona Lisa it was
hysterical that's funny it was like you
have to be creative and I feel like ever
since
um I think it was Simone who did Harriet
Tubman and now everyone has like stepped
their [__] up like and they're
singing out of the box yeah we can get
weird somebody did Rosie O'Donnell it
was hysterical it was hysterical and
then in the middle she transitioned to
Abby Lee Miller because she like kind of
looked like Abby Lee Miller too so good
so it's like really it's actually fun
and like inspiring to see them be like
so creative and last season
it was one of the worst snatch games
nobody everyone did so bad so this year
they like revamped it usually they wait
till like there's six Queens left and
it's so short it's like a five minute
segment this this season they have 12
people left they did two they cut them
up into six and six and it was like the
whole episode it was one long game show
snatch game it was so much better please
if anyone's listening keep it forever it
was so good it was so much better it's
the best part of the Season I'm so glad
they didn't make us wait like this this
new like they obviously had like a
revamp it's better keep everything as it
is please
okay
that's my recap great I'm glad you're
enjoying thank you tell me about Job
sick I know you had a
rev what's the word a revolutionary yeah
I guess that would be the right word
yeah it was a revelatory experience to
watch the show dope sick as you know I
read demon Copperhead last week which is
about a boy in Appalachia whose uh born
into a lot of Misfortune a lot of things
happen along the way including the
opioid crisis so then I don't know that
much about it really like happened early
2000s we were 10. so I had a lot of
catching up to do people recommended
watching Dope Sick which I had heard of
because it was like nominated last year
at every award Michael Keaton's in it
and I was like okay great that will you
know add color to the story and
I did not expect to feel this way about
the show I don't know if like all TV is
like this or they intentionally made the
show feel so addicting like I literally
started it Friday night I watched as
many as I could before I fell asleep and
then like Saturday I was thinking about
it all day like watched whenever I could
like when Harry was napping and then
finished it Saturday night like and the
show is about addiction I literally felt
like I was addicted to the show like I
wonder if that was just me or that's
also just TV in general which is kind of
why I hate starting a show because then
I'm like consumed by it like every
chance I get I'm like watching TV as
opposed to doing anything else that's
productive yeah so I'm not starting
another show for a while but I'm so glad
that I watched this show because it goes
back and forth in time between like the
beginning of Purdue Pharma creating
Oxycontin and all of the different ways
that they miss marketed it and straight
up lied lied about how this was like an
opioid that is non-addictive not only is
it not and is it addictive it's more
addicted than anything that's come
before it and more potent than
everything that came before it so in the
past people doctors would prescribe like
morphine for pain but like they know
you're getting morphine like uh you know
right it's a big deal heed with caution
yes but like this they're like 10
milligram oxy like they just made it
this whole thing where it just became so
casual and the way that the sales reps
would Market it
was just like they redefined what pain
management was what opioids meant like
for decades in this country like doctors
across the country were like advocating
for opioid use and that it like wasn't
harmful but it's just like as someone
with no particular like when I think of
opioids I'm just like the [__] you don't
get those for a toothache no
so the whole show was eye-opening and of
course everybody and so many people
reach out to me they're like I can't
believe the sacklers the sacklers
they're the family that owned Purdue
Pharma they like straight evil like yeah
created this product made it so
addictive kept on finding ways to get
people hooked to Market it to New
audiences to keep the people on it for
long amounts of time and that was like
horrible to watch but what I really took
away from it was like the government
collusion the way that the FDA like
people are gonna try and do bad things
but like perhaps we're supposed to have
systems in place to protect consumers to
protect the citizens and like the FDA
literally just like works for these
pharmaceutical companies like and they
they put this label on oxycontin which
is why doctors trusted it the FDA wrote
a new label that had never been seen
before on an opioid that was like less
than one percent of users become
addicted and then when you find out
eventually where they got that stat from
the garbage can there's no there's no
um clinical study there's no and it's
the complete opposite but it was like
that label people have trust in like
these governmental bodies and like when
you see something like that FDA approved
you're like oh okay but it means jack
[__] and to me that was my takeaway that
like
and it wasn't just the FDA because also
like the people at the DEA are trying to
like Tamp down the investigation people
at the justice department they keep
talking about main Justice they don't
even want to prosecute the people higher
up they just got misdemeanors over at
Purdue instead of being like criminally
indicted because like the government is
working against us I know and it's so it
was it was shocking to see and this is
literally 15 years right no and I feel
like that's constantly my take away from
different documentaries it's like all
like the FBI like any different like
whatever government agency or like big
system is like involved in the
documentary that you're working with
like they're always involved and they're
always corrupt and it makes you so
doubtful like you don't want to feel
crazy like you can't trust anyone but
every time I watch a documentary it's
like oh yeah Children's Services [__]
[__] up again FBI mother shipping
Services FBI [__] [__] up again it's
like FDA now it's like who can we trust
who can we trust even now with this
Bernie Madoff documentary which I
haven't watched this one uh I don't know
it's like a docu-series but I've watched
three in the past like I know the story
worry and like of course Bernie Madoff
is a horrible evil corrupt crook but the
SEC is a governmental body that is
supposed to keep people like him in
check and so many times his name came
across their desk his name was flagged
and they never did anything about it it
was all within their power and within
their control to do something about it
and that's why you [__] exist and
these companies these agencies like we
pay for them like they're 500 taxpayers
and like they're not looking out for us
they're they're literally they look at
like because then eventually if you work
at the SEC maybe you get a job with
Bernie Madoff you don't want to pick up
that's exactly what happened with the
FDA and this pharmaceutical companies
and it's like these people are not
looking out for you look out for
yourself is Purdue still like a pop-in
pharmaceutical I never heard I don't
think so
um because like the whole it was a
privately owned uh pharmaceutical
company by this family that has been
like shamed to high hell like they're as
they shift as they should that someone
who should be canceled
yeah yeah
well that actually does sound really
good but I feel like you told the story
with such no Claudia you you you can't
understand like I feel like also when
you hear about like the opioid crisis
like it kind of you feel like kind of
detached from it yes and like how
someone could fall into that you know
and I feel like that was something a
point they made in the documentary like
Purdue kept being like well addicts are
gonna addict and find a way to abuse
drugs right it's like if you had an
actual injury and you go to your doctor
because you're in pain like and they
give you Oxycontin it will be nearly
impossible for you to get off of it yeah
and then you just keep chasing that and
then you need more and more and more but
you can't get like they only prescribe a
certain amount so then you switch to
harder stuff that's cheaper that will
hit you faster and like and now we have
like an actual horrible drug epidemic in
this country yeah by the way I do feel
like I feel like it was so long ago like
when I hear about it like I think about
it similar to like the crack epidemic
which I think was in the 80s and it
feels so long ago and you're like oh
[__] was crazy back then but it's like
it wasn't that long ago it wasn't that
long ago and then people were messaging
me like because they're who like are
from Appalachia there like I left for
college I came back and it's still it's
just as bad here like we're not over it
and now it's morphed into like uh heroin
addiction and Fentanyl addictions and
that's like what we're seeing now with
like all of these overdoses and it's
just so horrible yeah but that does
sound very good you should watch it okay
you will and then you'll be talking
about it and I'll have you moved on to
checks cause check back next week for my
dopestick recap thank you
anyways if you've thought about watching
it and you haven't like 100 watch it but
carve out some time where you could like
watch it in one sitting because it's
impossible to break up right
just um well thank you for sharing that
that actually is very
informative
from informing people we've got a great
show today just a couple stories couple
of girls telling some stories a couple
of girls telling other people stories
never ever sharing about themselves no
we do have two secondang new iPads and I
feel like it's gonna be a great show
let's find out
without further Ado did it do here are
the past five stories that you need to
know
and today's episode is sponsored by
liquid IV New Year is here and there's
no better way to kick off 2023 than by
making sure you're feeling your best
self liquid IV is the category winning
hydration brand that is fueling your
well-being
and their hydration multiplier is the
one product that you're missing in your
daily routine one stick of liquid IV
you're getting five essential vitamins
and two times faster hydration than
water alone you use it first thing in
the morning before a workout when you
feel run down after a long night out and
on Long flights so in the liquid IV
stick it's uh a powder that you mix into
16 ounces of water and it'll hydrate you
two times faster it has B3 B5 B6 B12
vitamin C it has three times the
electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks it's non-GMO it has no gluten no
Dairy no soy so it's really really great
for you if you experience dehydration or
just overall fatigue and you'd feel like
you're not drinking enough water you're
not getting enough vitamins or you're
hungover or you get like exhaustion
headaches that's what happens to me I
always find myself reaching for my
liquid I viewed like three four o'clock
when I'm getting that light-headed like
headache because I haven't drank enough
water and I immediately feel better of
course I drink it when I'm hungover if
you get migraines mine are triggered by
dehydration liquid IV is such an easy
way that you don't like drink so much
water because the 16 ounces that you're
drinking are just doing more for you
they also are on a mission to change the
world they've donated over 25 million
servings in 50 countries around the
world they have delicious flavors I love
the acai berry but really there are no
bad flavors grab your liquid IV in bulk
nationwide at Costco or you can get 20
off when you go to liquidity.com and use
code toast at checkout that's 20 off
anything you order when you shop better
hydration using promo code toast at
liquid iv.com today's episode is also
sponsored by Squarespace so if you're
working in e-commerce looking to start a
side Hustle but you really don't know
where to start Squarespace is an amazing
resource
to help you get your business off the
ground or if you're looking to switch it
up so from websites online stores
marketing tools analytics Squarespace is
the all-in-one platform to build a
beautiful online presence and run your
business so they have a ton of different
features at um Squarespace that make it
really easy to get your business off the
ground if you are looking to build a
website but you don't have much
experience in design or like software
engineering like most people don't
Squarespace is going to take you through
it so easy you'll be a software engineer
in no time it is so easy to design your
templates to get really good data and
analytics to help link up your social
media to your website it's really good
place to start and of course we have a
code for you guys because if you go to
squarespace.com toast you'll get a free
trial and then when you're ready to
launch use our code toast you'll save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain
again that's code toast when you go to
squarespace.com toast once you're ready
to launch use that code save 10 off your
purchase first purchase of a website or
a domain that's also what I really like
about it if you're looking to get you
know Claudia is stunning.com they will
help you get access to that website
domain which can be really hard if you
don't know how to do that which is so
important for the success of your site
100 so squarespace.com toast that'll get
you a free trial and then when you're
ready to launch use code toast to save
10 off your first purchase of a website
or a domain
thank you mclared thank you so much
you're welcome our first story I would
say this is about 11 months late but
Kylie Jenner finally announced her baby
boy's new name and pronunciation so
Kylie posted on Saturday a carousel
images on Instagram with her and her son
air
a-i-r-e air Webster and he's very sweet
he's very cute yeah yeah I mean honestly
I don't think anybody guessed this name
it does make sense because she's clearly
going for like an elements themes you
know I love the elements I love the
elements it's giving Earth Wind and Fire
so I I like that there's a similarity
there of course you have to be different
you know put an e at the end and the way
she just like won random Saturday 11
months after her son was born decided
she just like you know hit us with a
name cool I there was a point where I
was so curious it killed me it kept me
up at night
and you know I did have to move on with
my life and that's exactly what I did so
like I wasn't gagged you know I don't
really care anymore but like cool
cool yeah I have two theories as to why
she shared it now
um air people were showing that in
Hebrew it means lion
and then she went to that Shia Pirelli
show
shrapnel show in Milan like yesterday or
this morning I don't know what time it
was and she was wearing a lion and so I
feel like she realized the meaning that
like she has a sun lion and she's in
this like Lion outfit and that would
that's like cool Synergy and she should
let us know that's her son's name in
advance like I get it but I don't think
Kylie wearing one dress would like
influence her I I think like she's was
gonna share the name eventually but
she's like oh this might be a good time
like I'm I like this dress like she's
having a lion moment let me explain to
everyone why I give a [__] about the
Lions for sure but does Kylie have a
connection to the Hebrew language
no but I feel like a lot of people well
actually like yes and no right if you're
Christian like the Old Testament like
you're connected to the Israelites like
yeah you're connected to the Hebrew
language and I feel like a lot of people
like look at like what names mean in
Hebrew it's just like a language do they
I don't know it kind of like not not
because it's a Biblical connection is
that right yeah it's like biblical yes
yeah okay or maybe I'm just like
delusional no I know like there are like
weirdly a lot of like very religious
it's not weird sorry I don't mean that
but like people who are like very
religious Christians have like Justin
Bieber has like a Hebrew tattoo yeah so
you know there's definitely a connection
I just I don't know he could be a Jew
and believe in God absolutely
but she's not a Christian so like Kylie
dropping her baby's name like honestly I
wasn't like I got a million messages
like oh my God like honestly I was not
gagged like I'm like kind of over it but
I was gagged over was Kylie in
Paris I feel like we haven't actually
physically seen like recent photos of
Kylie she looks amazing she looks kind
of different
I think she's just like lost a lot of
weight I know like there's some rumors
that she like looks different like she
got Buckle fat like what everyone's
doing like the jackal
I think it's buckle I actually think
it's buccal okay by the way I would I'm
not like I I actually think it's buckled
so okay okay
fat removal I like you know the jowl
which by the way everyone's doing is so
trendy cool I was like a way ahead of
the trends like I literally got all the
fat removed from my face like five years
ago is that what you got was it the
Buckle family
but Buckle is like your jowls and jaw
and like that's what I did
hmm
she looks amazing perhaps but she also
just like looks super slim and that
changes your face sometimes yeah she's
always been like fit but I feel like
she's a little skinnier than usual
that's like what everyone's going for
these yes well she was wearing that lion
dress a lot of people were like thought
it was like crazy and dumb I thought it
was like I thought it was fabulous I
think it looks great yeah she wore that
blue number she's really kind of
stepping out on these hoes in Paris no
sh but she's been doing that like for a
year now because remember last time she
went to Paris yes she was sickening
Paris down she was Paris was like this
I'm sick that's what I don't know when
she became the face of like Europe's
fashion week but I think it's good for
everyone yeah
yeah I'm loving seeing Kylie out and
about I missed her yeah
um and I'm glad we got a name because it
was like very it was weird I was very
curious for a while but I think also my
other Theory and then one other thing I
think whatever the name was I think she
wanted to wait till until it was legally
changed yeah of course until the
paperwork comes back and like that does
take a while yeah and three there's a
lot of rumors that her and Travis are
like not together right now that he
cheated blah blah blah and so like maybe
Travis was the one who didn't want air
out there yet and now she's like well
you cheated right and [__] you here we
love that
nothing more frightening than a woman's
scorned like your opinion no longer
matters 100 get out
um but now this does you know leave the
question of Chloe's baby
I know and I'm I just like I do get
really curious because I feel like these
people like celebrities and the
Kardashians like they invent names they
can't just obviously name their baby
yeah so
it's just like you wonder what it's
gonna be yeah
but I think air is great I will always
miss wolf like I have a special place in
my heart such a good day and now that I
have a face to the baby like I could see
him being wolfy I could too and like no
baby is gonna be a wolf like it's an Amy
grow into 100 you become the wolf you
did the wolf doesn't become you or you
become the lion
she was obviously going for like a
jungle theme
yeah but I love the elements stormy air
but it's also people were saying maybe
his name would be sunny but then you
have like one kid that's like that's
weird positive and one kid that's like a
storm that's kind of mean negative
they're
Elemental but different not being
compared yeah
yeah yeah like the next one could be
like ocean again that would work like
the ray oh no they have a rain
Ray
Everybody Loves Raymond yeah Ray Romano
like kind of ruined that name
Ray I'll give it right
well loving scene Kylie in Paris looking
forward to more content
yes
and I'm glad to have
close the book on this yeah me too like
it was time we're coming up on his first
birthday I did expect by the first
birthday I mean I would hope yeah
otherwise like she then she'll never
tell yeah
but then it's weird to have like one kig
and then the public and one kid not no
yes
are you ready for our next story yeah
Lisa Marie Presley's Memorial tribute
was on Sunday and Riley keough's husband
confirmed that he and Riley have a
daughter during his memorial speech so
during a memorial service for at least
Marie Presley at Graceland in Memphis on
Sunday wow Memphis I'm just not okay I
hope you got all that Mondays am I right
uh Riley keough's husband Ben Smith
Peterson revealed that the pair are
parents to a daughter while sharing a
tribute on behalf of his wife who was
seated in the front row he said quote I
hope I can love my daughter the way you
loved me this was Riley's letter that
she wrote but he read on her behalf
that's nice I hope I can love my
daughter the way you loved me the way
you love my brothers and sisters thank
you for giving me strength my heart my
empathy my courage my sense of humor my
manners my temper my wildness my
tenacity I'm a product of your heart my
sisters are a product of your heart my
brother is a product of your heart
that's sweet very sweet and I'm glad
that she was able to meet her
granddaughter there's no
indication of like when this baby was
how old who this but that she exists you
know that's nice I mean this the uh
the funeral was like streamed
right was it I think there was like
videos because I saw a bunch and Alanis
Morissette performed oh yeah and it
looks like there's it was set up as like
a televised thing yeah I
I don't understand why Alanis Morissette
performed like I wonder what the
connection is
maybe they're just like industry Pals
yeah
yeah or maybe like Alanis Morissette was
like Lisa Marie's favorite artist you
know
yeah
I'm going with industry Pals they seem
like they would be around the similar
age yeah
um Kaya Gerber was there with Austin
Butler it was star-studded it looked
really sad
um and I said Zach Graceland like I
think that's really
um like cool yeah and she'll be late to
rest there alongside Elvis and her son
that's nice yeah very very nice um and
Priscilla is a great grand
Priscilla's sorry I don't mean to twist
your brain
Priscilla's Lisa Marie's mother who was
Elvis's wife
so if Riley had a daughter that means
Priscilla a great grandmother and
Priscilla is alive Priscilla's alive oh
that's terrible yeah
to lose a daughter
rest in peace
rest in peace our next story is one of
the bigger newses from the weekend
because everybody was in Dubai for
Beyonce concert Beyonce sung through her
Decades of hits as she performed her
first full concert in four years in
Dubai after a four-year absence since
her last headlining show Beyonce
returned to the stage on Saturday
evening when she performed an hour-long
set at the new Atlantis the Royal Resort
in Dubai moving through a decade of
iconic hits she performed Staples such
as crazy in love Beautiful Liar and
naughty girl as well as more recent
Tunes including Freedom spirit and be
alive at one point during the show she
was joined on stage by her daughter and
her husband
so um I just want to say not to make
everything about me and I know I'm gonna
sound like Madison Beer like I was
supposed to be in the video uh but I
actually was invited to this
um I did did not want to go because it's
just too long of a flight for 48 hours
it was unpaid I'm running a business
like I can't be leaving for three days
like you know
not getting paid
um and I got regrets now no because I
first of all like I was interested I was
like looking into you know what other
influencers not to be so this is the
meanest thing I'm gonna ever say okay
okay but like I was you know reaching
out trying to see like if I knew anyone
going and it was like the roster of
talent that was going because you have
to think about who would agree to go to
something unpaid it wasn't anybody cool
like I wanted to be with cool people the
only cool person really there was
Kendall Jenner it's like she got paid
but nobody else
um yeah well so how who was going to
bring you like who's paying for it to
the Atlantis you want me to pull up the
email sure so but are you saying that
everybody was brought by the Atlantis
there weren't yes other brands with noon
that were like these are our
spokespeople
okay hold on a VIP invite Atlantis the
Royal opening weekend okay to join you
in a plus one with special guests
including Beyonce Kendall Jenner Swedish
House Mafia to the Grand reveal weekend
and the world's most Ultra Luxury oh my
God I'm hilarious Ultra luxury resort
Atlantis in Dubai very exclusive weekend
taking place before the resort is open
to guests Saturday night spectacular
front row seat to a 60-minute Beyonce
her live shows for show since 2018 then
Swedish House Mafia then they sent an
itinerary Friday there was a dinner and
an after party Saturday relaxed during
the day red carpet dinner at one of
their restaurants Beyonce show and then
fireworks and then brunch on Sunday so
it's like you get there Friday and you
leave Sunday and you have to take a
16-hour flight like my body's not built
like that right of course but the flight
is like fabulous and well they were also
offering business class and not first
class so that did change things but this
is class on no it's sick I'm totally
that was a joke thick yeah so it
includes the flights luxury
accommodation food and beverage bespoke
itinerary curated activities events and
experiences over the unforgettable
weekend so it was from the hotel and I
feel like that email sums up what the
weekend was like for me following other
people and I a lot of the influencers
who went like there were a lot of
reality stars
um
so a few people that I follow were there
and it looked like really everyone had a
great time no totally I feel like they
were so tired like I don't know how
you're not I know but it's like it's a
16 hour flight but if you're fly if
those 16 hours are like as premium as it
gets like it's not yeah but you are like
flipped on the time
yeah oh yeah yeah I was seeing some
tired people too but then like you know
it's an adventure no yeah and I feel
like if you're like an enormous Beyonce
fan like that was probably amazing I
feel like I'm in my lifetime I'm gonna
see Beyonce you know like I don't feel
like it was my only opportunity to see
Beyonce concert you know yeah so we're
saying yes to life but just not this
well did you say no in 20. I got it in
2022. I got the email in 2022 and like
to be honest I just like would have had
to like Miss like probably two episodes
of toast like for me like I'm always I'm
saying yes to life but it always is
against the barometer of how many toast
episodes I miss okay is there an artist
that would have gotten you to go Taylor
oh I would have gone if it was Taylor
okay
um and then I made a spot you know I
left a spot open for somebody who really
wanted to go
I wonder who got your spot yeah I hope
they had a great time
did Ben want to go uh kind of
Benja kind of did want to go and I was
like you can go
but he was like not without you I'm like
all right great good answer good cause
it's what you got yeah no it just it
wasn't the right timing for me it was
Ben's sister's birthday like I really
couldn't go okay
we understand anyways it was uh it looks
like a great fabulous weekend that
you know people were excited to be a
part of yeah no and the Beyonce
performance looked sick I heard they
paid Beyonce 36 million dollars that was
my next question I didn't know that a
figure had emerged yes they said that is
that's in line with like how much they
must have spent on like just flying
everyone there this hotel looks insane
and it's like Beyonce's first concert in
four years you're gonna pay up I heard
36 million dollars like 88 million of
the Arabic currency which is a 36
million USD
where'd you hear that the interwebs Tick
Tock yeah
and they were like very strict about
phones no video they must be releasing
it somewhere like Beyonce must have a
deal or something
um but you know that many people the
whole thing got leaked
yeah well or maybe like in the hotel you
could stream it just like exclusive to
Atlantis oh perhaps like I don't know
what they're gonna do with the footage
but it was definitely recorded and like
maybe if you go to the one in the
Bahamas you could watch it there too
okay that's where we'll go yeah two
hours that's like saying I love the
Atlantis I hope they have a leap of
faith there I know Atlantis is a great
great chain of hotels where else do they
have them I think just Dubai and Bahamas
and they've had one in Dubai for a while
remember the Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills stayed there but they opened the
second location and this is their like
Ultra Luxury one that's what I was gonna
ask because I thought there was already
in Atlantis it took me a while to like
piece together what this weekend was
about at first I was like oh a couple
people I thought are going to Dubai like
they should hang out and then I was like
oh and they're all at the Atlantic
attacking the Atlantis and I was like
yeah oh and it's a new Atlantis I was
like it wasn't there an old Atlantis and
Beyonce's there and then I was like I
think Claudia was invited to that and
then yeah and then
um like the difference so they have the
Atlantis I think it's like a little bit
more touristy this like I think it's
called like the I forget what the name
is Royal Atlantis like Beyonce's room
and she probably stayed at the nicest
room in the hotel is 400 Grand a night
so it's like it's Ultra it's for like
you know the oil tycoons
of the world yeah but then I feel like
people don't even pay it they get it
everyone gets it for free yeah
crazy is there a casino
they're my spoon can you gamble there ah
I don't know because I think gambling is
against the law in the UAE yeah
I think you're right
Atlantis
the royal
ground
I could see I feel like even if they
don't like the tourism board they make
up for it's like they have crazy
activities there like you could ski oh
you could see you can see no but you
can't gamble you can't gamble yeah but
like what they lack in casinos they make
up for and like crazy ass activities
literally you can go to the water park
and next door you could go skiing yeah
like it's one of those crazy like
Adventure type of people you will not be
bored no you will not
uh that's awesome looks like a great
weekend and
um excited that Beyonce is doing her
thing yeah all shows great yeah we
didn't even recap in our TV recap the
game last night oh my God yeah like
we're such fraudulent News sports show
well it was such a great game I know
it's tough for you because like you
technically like had to root for Dallas
but for you like anyone who wins is a
winner it was yes and I had a lot of
thoughts along the way I I was thinking
really who I'm rooting for and at the
end I did come away rooting for the
Cowboys because if the Cowboys made it
to the Super Bowl I would probably be
going to the Super Bowl so then I was
like okay that would be cool like for
Harry and
um like that would be Harry at the bowl
and like he's a Super Bowl baby like it
would have been released Harry was born
on the Super Bowl so I was rooting for
the Cowboys but after watching the game
and it was it I think it was really good
football yeah
I think that's what people would say I
came to the conclusion that even if the
Cowboys had Inked out a win they're not
a Super Bowl ready team and they
wouldn't be winning the Super Bowl if
they even made it there like the 49ers
have what it takes and the Cowboys don't
so they played really good game last
night but they're gonna need some more
star players for next season they did
their best they absolutely have to cut
that guy the kicker missed again twice
no but all their points were kicks yeah
but like he had it still missed two I
think the status he missed the last six
out of nine or six out of ten
in the game for in the last two games
unacceptable I agree but last night he
did good
he did okay he still missed two
oh so then the score would have been it
wouldn't have made a difference
it was like 9 to 16 right no they lost
by seven oh so it would have been yeah I
think the Cowboys should be really proud
of them for a number of years via my
husband and they've never looked at this
good before they're really coming up and
it wasn't their time but like I think
they're really close but they need you
know they don't have those those they
don't have like those wide receivers and
running backs like the 49ers do so now
the interesting thing is that the winner
of this game plays the Philly Eagle the
Philadelphia Eagles which is obviously
like an hour and a half drive from here
and now it's the Niners and I want to go
um and I've been in contact we have many
toaster wives and girlfriends of Eagles
players and they really want us that
would be traitorous well no I just I
like I need some tickets and like they
understand my loyalty but I will say
like I'm kind of like scared and
everyone was messaging me like you know
if you go like do not wear Niners gear
like so I feel like I I can get tickets
um
but I feel like for my own protection
like I really need to be in a suite
like honestly people were like actually
they were scaring me like fear-mongering
in my DMs
like you talk yeah you get slapped I'm
like oh so like you just talked [__]
about about Philly in the past and it
seems like not much has changed over
there and I could like see it being
played on the Jumbotron what you said
and then they would be like Claudia
section c right seat 300. get her so I
need some sort of like police protection
like an escort I need a box so like
that's gonna be like a safe space for me
so if someone can reach out because like
I have tickets but honestly I don't feel
safe in the stands
would you go Incognito like not wear
representing your team I I was talking
to some of the the wives and girlfriends
and they were like you cannot wear your
Niners gear
um so I said I would wear toast merch
yeah then they're like okay who's this
clown if my face is so recognizable as
being like such a Niners fan like one of
the more famous Niners fans I
understand so I'm gonna need like
somebody to arrange like a back entrance
for me like where are the
friends and family of the Niners really
good seats in like a section but it's in
the stands and I'm nervous but if they
can sit there you can sit there oh of
the Niners yeah yeah but nobody would
dare [__] with like a a nine or wife
they would never but they would [__]
with you a civilian a lowly a lowly
chubby like at a Towner they would
totally totally do that yeah
that's what I'm struggling with but I do
really want to go to the game on Sunday
because it's so Philly is so close Okay
so like maybe you can get
someone who has a suite who's like not
super invested yeah and if there's like
a retired code who wants to escort me
through the facility I'm like actually
scared why don't you just hire security
I need to get a ticket for him too
that's the thing that's always what I
wonder about like celebrities and their
security like how do they get them into
places it's like hard enough to get into
a club just you and your girlfriends a
hundred percent I also I think I will be
going with Taylor Donahue who's like a
big Eagles fan so hopefully she can like
bring my she can like provide cover yeah
I know and like show like increase my
cool factor in the stadium and I'm sure
if Ben goes he'll wear an eagles Jersey
because he's a fair weather fan no the
thing is I was you know thinking about
it last night like I couldn't look to
use checks in the face if I wore an
eagles Jersey I couldn't no and it's
like this is a moment in life where you
have to be scrupled and you have to
stand up for what you believe in even
though it's not popular I know no Sports
is such a scruple to like field
literally yeah but I've never really
considered that or heard of that it's
like unsafe for the opposing only in
Philly
and that's no that's a fact that's like
a fact can I you want to read you
through my DMs I was like should I go to
Philly here's what my response ready
yeah there's and there's no other place
that's at passionate I mean you guys let
me know like
okay hold on
I wonder which which um
team has the nicest fans probably the
Cleveland Browns went to the Eagles
stadium when they played the Falcons in
2018 as a Falcons fan and someone spit
on me 10 out of 10 don't recommend so
stay safe if you do queen
okay I don't think you would handle that
well
LOL you're gonna get dragged out
oh goodness
wait like it's insane
in all honesty this is probably not your
best idea Philly is different just a
word of advice people are being really
serious
Philly is different okay Billy is so
mean lol Philly fans reminding us all
that they're the worst Eagles fans are
so hostile I would worry about your
safety as a 49er like I got a thousand
messages I'm just scrolling through my
messages
Eagle fans are the best always so nice
and never rude or aggressive
so I'm actually like I'm concerned yeah
and I don't know if this is just
everyone like fear-mongering me
no those seem legit like legit concerns
so like you should take into account so
now it's like I just got in we just got
into football like you don't need to
really like take a hit for your team
just yet I'd literally gonna be like
Marcia Brady like oh crap my nose
yeah that's gonna be me getting hit in
the face no you're also you're gonna be
like going and you're gonna wear your
49ers shirts and you're gonna expect
like everyone to hate you but really
everyone's gonna ignore you of course
make up that something happened this
person looked at me no the thing is I'm
scared
I understand so I think you should wait
and see if like the right opportunity
comes across your lap like I need police
protection yeah well you could hire
somebody it's so dramatic like nobody
literally so traumatic you could bring
security with you if you really wanted
to like I'll tell Taylor Johnny you're
like sorry actually you can't have the
ticket I need to bring this with my
bodyguard
this retired cop has to escort me
through the facility that's so funny
they should really like break out the
stadium by sections of fans no yeah yeah
no but I like that's just like the
culture in Philly I think like they like
it like that yeah
and I think that's like you know
football culture in general you're not
really a part of it but they're like
yeah so I'm gonna stick with my toast
merch
or the bar sweatshirt
I have so many but where the red one
actually no you're done you're done you
would be done yeah you would be finished
you'd never work in this town again nope
okay let's get into our next story are
you ready for it if it's brought to you
by the perfect bar if you're looking for
a protein bar that actually tastes good
well look no further than perfect bar
with their lineup of fresh from the
fridge protein bars perfect bar is
exactly what you've been looking for no
chalky artificial aftertaste here so
they're made with freshly ground nut
butter organic honey and 20 organic
superfoods perfect bar has a variety of
products like protein bars little snack
size bars that are also good and good
for you
um whatever your like palette is you'll
find something you like because I love
you know me I'm so picky the dark
chocolate chip peanut butter with sea
salt chef's kiss it is so delicious my
go-to snack also kind of love that you
have to keep them in the fridge because
like they're actually made with real
food not like crazy ass chemicals or
preservatives
um the texture is also really
interesting it kind of tastes like
cookie dough it's really creamy it's
full of flavor and they're unlike any
other bars out there and now they come
in snack size which is great to throw in
your purse when you're traveling or you
have a long day they have six grams of
proteins 150 calories and they go a long
way they're the they're made with only
whole food ingredients and they contain
no artificial preservatives they are
stored in the fridge so grab one after a
workout or for a quick bite while you're
out holiday shopping and feel good about
what you're snacking on
so perfect bar knows that it'll be Love
At First Bite for a limited time they're
offering you a chance to try their
refrigerated non-GMO gluten-free soy
free and kosher bars for free here's how
it works sign up for email or text
upload a picture of your receipt from
your local grocery store and they will
reimburse you at the cost of one bar
it'll go directly into your venmower
PayPal account all you have to do is go
to perfect snacks.com toast to get that
free perfect bar that's perfect
snacks.com toast happy snacking
happy snacking that made me hungry
that's perfect bars it doesn't take much
to make me hungry
are you ready for our next story because
Selena Gomez and Drew Taggart were
holding hands during a New York City
date night so I really thought we put
this behind us and we had sorted it out
um but they're going hard with this
narrative Selena was spotted holding
hands with quote from page six new bow
Drew Taggart in New York City over the
weekend despite the singer saying she
was single in a since deleted Instagram
story post earlier this week the two
appeared to be very much a couple while
grabbing dinner at theresi bar and
restaurant in Soho on Saturday
it's a very
um sceny spot like they weren't trying
to be seen
okay that is Jermaine thank you I've
never heard of this restaurant so I
thought maybe it was low-key it sounds
like you know it's like a little bar
they went to
um but they were trying to be seen it is
the brand new location
um from the same owners as Carbone it's
like a very hot spot so I'll have to go
yeah uh it's like the new place so they
were trying to be seen it's celeb
fave Paparazzi it's so to me I get
annoyed when people say one thing and do
the other like it's misleading Selena
doesn't always an explanation of
anything but like to say you're single
and then be out holding hands on a date
like make it make sense I I hate being
confused
agreed I'm sticking to my guns these two
are not an item and the fact that they
went to a cine restaurant to go on a
date proves to me that this is PR and I
think loophole that Selena wasn't lying
because as stated last week that thing I
am single is her song and that's the
first lyric like ice I literally we
cracked it put my life on it I like
being too much to dance with your heart
sometimes I get lonely late at night up
in the dark
I am real I am brave I am me
me May
uh I think that also like this way
Selena's not lying to her fans I don't
think she would ever want to be thought
to be someone who's not just set their
fans deceptive and so this makes
everything make sense now why you need
to hold hands with the person you're
collaborating with you know what maybe
she was wearing big heels no you could
be wearing heels it's dark Paparazzi
flash is so bright and so fast like you
kind of do need someone to guide you
through usually it's like a
bodyguard or like a publicist but it's
actually hard to walk straight in the
dark when there's a thousand flashes
it's like it's not normal so maybe
that's why they were holding hands yeah
uh maybe I think that again what I'm
looking at her outfit this is not a date
night outfit right I think that maybe
they went to the studio they're going to
get some grub this is a new Hot Spot
like it's really good and I think maybe
they threw a handhold in there because
they are enjoying this narrative it's
good for the single there's definitely a
song coming out yeah
I like being alone too much to dance
with your heart
but when I get lonely I get lonely in
the dark yeah when I get lonely I get
lonely that's so true
this sometimes it really takes two
profound Queens to go beyond the surface
lyrics let's write let's write this song
together you're actually really good
with words yeah and you're really good
with music melodically
melodically do you want to go for
another verse
no I think we should like keep some like
you know keep part of it private because
what if they haven't written the song
yet and they're literally just watching
these episodes and copying it down
don't play with me because that would be
like my worst fear
that would also be like your
your biggest hope yeah of course
that someone somewhere is watching the
show oh right like somebody with even a
remote amount of influence watches this
show show yourself
all of a sudden she's backstage at The
Chainsmokers yeah like whipping my hair
back New York City please go easy on me
tonight oh
I wanna be like Kanye that was like a
good song too bad it's ruined honestly
all of their songs are so good I agree
like if you're being honest don't let me
don't let me don't let me they actually
haven't released a banger in a really
long time maybe this is Selena thing is
like their big comeback this is like the
one and it's Selena's big comeback
because they've been kind of irrelevant
you love to call people irrelevant I
have like when when people take a break
that's unfortunately like the world we
live in it's like someone new and hot
and young ready to take your spot that's
why like when they got announced on call
her daddy I was like oh that's so weird
they're like irrelevant
but they're working on their comeback
yeah they are and I think Selena has a
lot to do with it the caller daddy
interview had a lot to do with it they
released a single
um just three days ago called make me
feel gotta take a listen Okay and their
album was in 2017 memories
and like then they just had Banger after
Banger of course that Halsey song which
is like I think one of the biggest songs
ever made so baby pull me
and also something just like this with
Coldplay I want something just like this
also we were staying in Paris
yeah so good
yeah these are talented guys oh a
hundred percent
so
Selena
make yourself known yeah
really Unriddle this riddle for us
hashtag I am the single while we still
gave a [__] do it while we still give a
[__] someone please it's so true are you
ready for a fifth and final Story the
vinyl
Harry Hamlin is spilling the real reason
why Lisa Rinna left Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills and if the reason wasn't
so crazy I wouldn't be reporting it oh
this is and how he's a serious guy so
like he doesn't just say stuff
um a page six spy overheard Hamlin
telling a group of people during the
Sundance Film Festival on Saturday that
the reason Lisa Rinna might still uh why
renum how she might have still been on
the show
quote Lisa
he said it's because viewers sided with
Sutton Strack in the co-stars Feud over
the Elton John Gala tickets
yeah Lisa had all the receipts from that
night but they never showed the receipts
on the reunion
she might still be on the show had
Sutton not said that he continued
according to the spies she might still
be on the show but the audience believed
Sutton okay now take all this with a
grain of sauce it's like overheard at a
party that's just incorrect right no of
course it's over here at a party a spy
is jotting down quotes how did he have a
tape recorder on him so like consider
the source but that Harry Hamlin is
saying that Lisa chose to leave because
the viewers took set inside or maybe
like Bravo asked her because the viewer
just took a set inside about the Elton
John thing but in reality they didn't
show the whole picture okay he's not
wrong but I think he's just thinking of
the wrong situation like
she left slash was fired because
the viewers took Kathy's side he's right
I think John girl is irrelevant and
every time they talked about I was like
I roll I roll and you know what Sutton
shut her down with those receipts like
she did
yeah but apparently she had receipts at
the reunion which I do remember like a
clip that never was in the actual thing
yeah she went on like social media or
something and said like I brought a
manila envelope with that Elton John
information and it never made the cut I
have a hard time believing if it was
like you know
if it was not like if it was irrefutable
proof they would have kept it like I
don't know why they would have deleted
it and
I feel like
Sutton's proof that she brought up in
the show the receipts were irrefutable
like it's receipt it's right there
yeah like actual receipt not like
receipt no like the receipt for the
monetary amount that she spent on the
table
I'm now questioning what Harry said at
what was overheard because also if you
read it differently Lisa had all the
receipts from that night but they never
showed the receipts on the reunion maybe
it's all the receipts from that night
and then it's like it might have gone
differently if Sutton had not said that
that was another quote maybe Sutton said
something about the Kathy thing that
changed hearts and Minds the person
listening in is a [__] um and is just
spreading lies because Harry definitely
didn't say that I don't think he said
these things in the way that they're
reporting I don't think that's what he
believes I don't think it's about Elton
John's thing but at Bravo Khan Andy
vehemently denied that they had any sort
of footage or anything that would help
us put the pieces together from that
night in Aspen and of course he could
have lied but he was like why would we
not include that we like it would be
good for us
I don't think that they have anything
right but maybe like Lisa thought
remember how she was showing text
messages of like what Kathy was saying
like you know
and things that she had sent to Erica
best keep quiet yeah like maybe Lisa
considers those receipts I don't
consider them anything like yeah and
what Lisa texted Erica again like is not
a primary source but you know what at
the end of the day even if she had
something on Kathy and they shared it I
don't even think it would have made a
difference because at the end of the day
it's not really so much about who's
right and who's wrong it's just about
who's likable and Kathy is very likable
and people like her and they don't like
Lisa like that's what it was
yes and also I think she did say half
that [__] in general with Housewives you
take the side of the person unless it's
like two people who are
neither are a fan favorite and neither
are the villain and we're just trying to
get to the facts but in general like you
take the side of the person that you
like yeah but then I always see like a
few seasons later things turn and then
you go back and you look at it and
you're like Lisa Renault was right so
true what's happening now with Lisa
Vanderpump because now the Serena went
down so we're like vanderpumper as well
right and like whoever came before
Vanderpump whatever talk [__] about her
were like they were right so it's like
we all have to just kind of question
ourselves it's like well yeah but let's
just go if we keep deciding with the
person who we like and not based on like
actual facts then yeah in time we'll see
but I just feel like that's how the
world works like the longer you're
silent the more of a hero you're gonna
appear to be because you're just letting
everyone else spin out you know I don't
think that necessarily means you were
right in that moment no I don't think
it's about like being silent let
everyone spinning out but it's like they
like you right now so they're going to
take your side whether you're right or
wrong because you can do no wrong but
then when they don't like you everything
you've ever done before is wrong I just
feel like with Vander pump like I didn't
even like all the other women that much
but like she clearly was like a diva and
like a problematic Queen
yeah but she definitely is looking more
favorable now of course
and like you know now Yolanda's looking
good
yeah
you know yeah yeah yeah even though like
Yolanda came off looking pretty good
like with the Munchausen thing
yeah but then why did she have to leave
bless you excuse me because you know
what she got what she wanted from the
show her daughters became Superstars
what the [__] does she need to hang
around with these women for
did she leave I think she left I do not
think she was fired yeah why does she
need to hang out with these women who
like are calling her Munchausen right
and she was like actually really
focusing on her health like she couldn't
film when she was going to seal to like
lay in a you know a hyperbaric chamber
yeah so I do think she left on her own
honestly
yeah
so that's her show uh
thank you all so much for spending the
time with us being a part of it we hope
you have an amazing day thank you so
much for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the fast five stories you need to know
every Monday through Friday on YouTube
so watching us on YouTube please don't
forget to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcast can be found
set Spotify iTunes tetrapublics all the
places where we listen to podcast find
us the toasty five star review about a
beautiful stunning smart and wicked lit
talented we are hope you guys have an
increa Monday and we'll see you tomorrow
on Tuesday bye love you bye